let's go to lieutenant chris alevarez
the texas department of public safety
he's been monitoring this unfortunately
uh he and his men and women in ways that
you cannot imagine always good to have
you lieutenant we're learning that the
administration kind of wants to do what
the governor of texas has been doing and
take some of these who are apprehended
at the border and bring the points
further north i think the difference
with the president's plan is to keep
them in texas but can you update us on
that
good afternoon yes you're right you're
right on point with that so all it's
going to do it's great for the smaller
border communities that are along the
border because it alleviates the
overcrowding and some of those mass
releases of these immigrants that are
being released into the smaller
communities but all it's going to do is
there all they're doing is transporting
those immigrants to a larger facility in
larger cities and then ultimately going
to transport them to their final
destination so it doesn't solve the
solution this is not an end result all
it's going to do is as i mentioned is
continue to transport these immigrants
through the process to larger cities and
from there to the ultimate destination
and with that messaging all it's going
to do is just create more um you know
chaos at the border and what i mean by
chaos is they mean large massive groups
of immigrants coming across and that's
what we're talking about right now and
the single adults the runners that got
aways over 440 000
known got aways for this fiscal year we
still have five more months to go and
we're not even taking into account the
unknown got aways that go undetected
they don't set off any cameras any
sensors those are the individuals that
we need to focus on and worry about
because again we don't know who they are
and where they end up
yeah to the your point we're just
showing that screen showing the uh the
encounters in may i believe a little bit
north in 239 thousand lieutenant i know
it's a guess
uh but those are known encounters not
good many of them get away right so
there's no way of handicapping the
godaways but even if it were ten percent
uh you're talking some serious numbers
you are and even with the known
guidelines that's just an estimating
they're going based off cameras they're
not based off you know foot tracks they
see out there that doesn't even give you
an exact number of how many would be in
that particular group so that's just an
estimate that 440 000 the number is much
higher and of course those individuals
you don't know who they are and you
actually put hands on them actually
apprehend them and properly bet them to
find out exactly what their criminal
histories are what their intentions are
where they're going and this is where
you know border patrol even our state
troopers come across you know criminal
gang members those with violent criminal
history sex crimes that are trying to
make it further into the interior and
blend in with these family groups and
that's what we've been seeing most
recently these large family groups that
are coming across unaccompanied children
you do have single adults that are mixed
in with those groups so again just goes
to show you how the tactics are changing
with the human smugglers they're taking
full advantage of this current border
crisis and these massive groups of
immigrants that are coming across along
the southwest border
and those massive groups now are a lot
more varied than they used to be we're
learning as well that now there's a good
sampling from latin america we could see
a new influx coming from colombia that
country just elected its first
member of the m19 guerrilla movement as
its president and a lot of people are
interpreting that as a struggle for the
colombian economy if he does some of the
things he's talked about so you could
get a new migrant wave from from you
know central and south america on top of
what we're already seeing what do you
say
right i mean that's exactly what we're
gonna that's what we're anticipating i
mean of course there's always gonna be
changes when you have different changes
in governments from other countries and
of course they're gonna take full
advantage of this current situation
where essentially the border is open
because you're having thousands and
thousands of immigrants coming across
record number after record number i mean
last month for the month of may over 239
000 that's a record high for dhs so this
goes to show you the numbers have not
decreased they continue to increase and
continue to escalate and not just in
terms of mass migration but also
national security when you talk about
drugs fentanyl we have never dealt with
a fentanyl crisis and now we're seeing
hundreds of americans are dying every
day nearly 300 americans die every
single day because of fentanyl poisoning
so just goes to show you that it's just
more it's just more of an immigration
issue this is a national threat you know
to not only the smaller communities but
also to the entire country how as these
drugs continue to pour into the country
and kill americans and also the
criminals that are trying to get by and
make it further into the interior
you're absolutely right you did call it
an emergency many many months ago chris
uh lieutenant chris antavaris hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now